voici un sous-marin de l'entreprise au
schengate c'est un petit submersible qui
permet de transporter jusqu'à 5
personnes à une très grande profondeur
soit jusqu'à l'épave du célèbre Titanic
l'expédition commence à Saint-Jean
Terre-Neuve et dure environ 8 jours
puisque le trajet est long il faut se
rendre à 600 km des côtes et après de
3800 mètres de profondeur au cours des
deux dernières années Ocean gate a
réussi à mener à bien se tourner du
Titanic permettant à des touristes de
découvrir cette merveille pour une somme
de 250 000 dollars américains mais cette
fois les nouvelles ne sont pas
rassurantes qu'elle appelle depuis hier
à 370 km de Terre-Neuve un navire de la
Garde côtière canadienne et l'Aviation
royale canadienne participe aux
recherches menées par la Garde côtière
américaine
je ne peux vous exprimer la peur que
j'ai pour ces personnes d'icône qui
connaît bien l'expédition en juillet
2022 il était du voyage avec son fils
Christian ils ont vu de près le Titanic
et l'aventure a été incroyable dit-il
le Titanic un paquebot britannique avait
quitté l'Angleterre en avril 1912 avec
2200 passagers à son bord
quelques jours plus tard au large des
côtes canadiennes il a heurté isberg et
il a coulé un tiers des passagers
seulement à survécu le Premier ministre
de terre-neuveville Labrador entho Fiori
écrit sur Twitter je pense à toutes les
personnes touchées nous espérons que la
Garde côtière américaine va réussir à
repérer le submersible et ceux qui sont
à bord la Garde côtière américaine
confirme que cinq personnes sont à bord
du sous-marin qui manquent à l'APL
depuis dimanche matin au schengate ne
révèle pas leur identité ici Michel
Bridou Radio-Canada
président des plongeurs des pavs
techniques du Québec je Pelletier
bonsoir bonsoir bon on va revoir
l'échelle de profondeur parce que c'est
quand même fascinant un plongeur normal
quand il fait ce qu'on appelle des
plongées profondes à nos profondes c'est
40 mètres 120 pieds le succession de
plus habitués en pieds pour les plonger
ça c'est déjà profond là l'épave de
l'impression Verlaine par exemple est à
45 mètres
sous-marin nucléaire ça sera à 500
mètres un peu moins et là on parle de
presque quatre kilomètres au fond des
mers c'est énorme monsieur Pelletier
aucun homme peut se rendre là avec des
de l'équipement conventionnel enfin
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui absolument pas
absolument pas c'est une profondeur qui
mais bon c'est mal parti disons là ce
qui arrive c'est que ce type de plongée
là les passagers sont dans un habitacle
qui est pressurisé donc ce qui fait en
sorte que le sous-marin peut se rendre à
une très grande profondeur et lors de la
remontée n'aura pas à se soumettre à une
obligation de décompression c'est ce qui
est l'avantage parce que un sous-marin à
l'origine ça devait être stratégique
c'était militaire donc s'il fallait en
plus être obligé d'attendre avant de
remonter bref ça enlever toute l'intérêt
stratégique d'avoir un tel appareil donc
le but c'était de pouvoir remonter
redescendre constamment sans nécessiter
de décompression mais ce genre
d'appareils de submersible qui a été
utilisé que l'on cherche il doit pas en
avoir beaucoup là je comprends qu'on est
à la recherche d'un autre qui va qui est
en chemin pour aller tenter de descendre
lui aussi pour retrouver leur mais il
doit pas en avoir beaucoup de ses engins
là on les compte sur les doigts de la
main c'est des
sur les doigts de la main je pourrais
vous parler du Nautile qui est
d'ailleurs le sous-marin avec lequel les
premiers explorateurs ont réussi à
observer de visu les restes de l'épreuve
du Titanic en 1987 donc c'est un
sous-marin très très fonctionnel très
performant qui est opéré par liffremer
qui est l'Institut français d'étude pour
la mère qui est basée à Brest en
Bretagne si ma mémoire est bonne donc
c'est un sous-marin qui est capable
d'intervenir à de telles profondeurs
maintenant il y a le sous-marin Titan de
ou Triton si ma mémoire est bonne
l'explorateur américain Victor vescovo
avec lequel il a pu se rendre dans les
points les plus profonds de chaque océan
du globe dans les dernières années donc
il a été capable d'atteindre la
profondeur de des forces de Marianne qui
est après de 11 km donc plus de deux
fois la profondeur laquelle se trouve le
RMS Titanic et là celui-ci que l'on
cherche il n'est pas relié au bateau là
donc une façon
autonome Tottenham il descend en
principe il remonte tout seul comment
peut-on d'abord un le trouver peut-être
le trouver des sauna mais comment
peut-on leur monter
en fait le remonter lui-même
c'est quelque chose sans sans me lancer
dans toutes les opérations navales de
haute technologie qui sont accessibles à
ce type
d'intervention là ça reste que le point
de départ c'est de premièrement
localiser le sous-marin
donc pour ça il faut que un sous-marin
puisse mettre un signal donc une balise
à l'heure actuelle selon ce qu'on en
comprend il n'y a pas de signal qui a
été repéré ça c'est déjà une mauvaise
nouvelle il a pu quoi
implosé
vivant le sait même pas s'ils le sont
ils savent qu'il leur reste quoi trois
jours et demi d'oxygène parce qu'il a
été apporté disparu je crois à partir de
21h30 hier
c'est un sous-marin très innovant c'est
un sous-marin d'ailleurs qui n'avait pas
reçu la certification d'agence comme la
Loize comme le marqueur bureau
le véritable etc donc c'est tellement
innovant qu'il y avait pas encore reçu
la créditation officielle c'est pas un
sous contrôle de titane c'est pas un
sous-marin en acier c'est un sous-marin
en carbone on le voit le sur les images
avec un hublot de 60 cm donc c'est c'est
une technologie tellement nouvelle que
peut-être qu'elle n'a pas été testée à
la limite nécessaire si on veut le pour
être capable de lancer de tel de telles
aventures de telles explorations ça fait
partie des dangers quand on va à des
limites
presque inconnues quand on dépasse les
limites là ça fait partie des dangers
oui ben en fait c'est un peu le
malheureux contexte de la
marchandisation des environnements
extrêmes extrêmement hostile on peut
maintenant payer un gros montant aller
dans l'espace on peut sans beaucoup
d'expérience d'alpinisme on peut
atteindre le sommet de l'Everest donc
tout ça fait en sorte que ces lieux qui
sont normalement extrêmement dures à
atteindre deviennent accessibles sauf
qu'il faut jamais oublier que c'est une
entreprise extrêmement risquée il y a
toujours un risque qui arrive quelque
chose et dans le cas présent
malheureusement pour l'instant comme je
vous dis en début on va espérer un
miracle mais malheureusement le fait
d'avoir toujours pas de signal de ne pas
avoir repéré en surface la carcasse du
sous-marin c'est pas de bonne augure on
comprend bien Sébastien Pelletier merci
je rappelle vous êtes président les
plongeurs dépassent technique que du
Québec merci beaucoup
moins profondes heureusement vous l'avez
dit en entrée de jeu on a un joyau là
c'est magnifique absolument c'est une
des plus belles épaves de l'époque de
l'époque Edouardienne un des seuls
plongeables et on l'a on l'a au large de
Rimouski donc ça se fait par quelqu'un
qui est un peu entraîné puis l'eau est
claire l'eau est froide pas très claire
parfois elle est pas très clair c'est
c'est quand même un environnement style
très sombre beaucoup de particules
parfois c'est beau parfois c'est pas
beau avec un drive soude parce qu'il
fait froid c'est mieux merci Sébastien
Pelletier